bon tu profites bien de ton père
on se retrouve dans cette dodo d'accord
allez il y a papa qui est là
salut
gros câlins bisous
[Musique]
[Rires]
non mais il me l'a rendu dans un état la
semaine dernière elle était dégueulasse
il avait pas lavée non mais tu te rends
compte il a pas sa fille cet [ __ ]
c'est dingue
c'est pas les papas minettes c'est juste
qu'il était beaucoup trop occupé à
baiser sa [ __ ] pardon
on va vous reprendre une bouteille de
rosé s'il vous plaît merci
je vais prendre un demi merci ça va et
toi
il y a de plus en plus de clodos dans
ton quartier là
on était sur l'autre [ __ ] qu'il a fera
sa fille non mais franchement je vous en
supplie vous fait déjà bien assécher
comme ça quand vous les avez alors soyez
mignonnette cette semaine vous allez
faire comme si vous étiez comme moi
seul alcoolique libre et heureuse
[Musique]
attends on est parti pour une semaine
entière d'apéro là c'est grâce mat
depuis
non pas la chance pardon mais il est
marié son mec ça compare
on peut plus faire les difficiles mariés
ou pas on prend désolé
franchement moi là je suis un mec je me
base
pas moi toi je te baise évidemment tout
le monde te baise mais moi là
franchement je me galoche et encore si
je suis beau
moi je te baiserai si j'étais un mec
c'est vrai oui ça va
non mais arrête sérieusement tu as vu
comme ils ont maté trois mec quand on
est monté là non j'ai pas vu de toute
façon j'imagine
tu regarderas ils sont à gauche en
descendant qu'à un moment donné
ok on fait pas notre âge c'est clair ou
pas
[Musique]
après ça vous dit d'aller au showroom
j'ai fini ma nouvelle collection
j'ai une idée de tenue de scène pour ton
nouveau spectacle ça va être des moments
c'est gentil mais j'ai pas écrit une
ligne donc pas de souci je serai pas à
poil grâce à toi merci
une muse et on va reprendre la même
chose dernière
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est trop fort le café aussi
[Applaudissements]
elle a une culotte
merci merci
[Musique]
et toi
tu es ma bagnole cette nuit apparemment
là alors les clodos c'était nous
tu te rappelles pas
vrai
oui alors
après le progrès tu as voulu aller
s'est transformé en trois bouteilles
on a fait après
tu as voulu absolument mettre ta chanson
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bah oui mais moi il faut pas me laisser
faire
donc tu as voulu aller au resto tu
voulais absolument conduire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention
on va aller dîner un très bon restaurant
[Musique]
quoi ouais non je vais te rappeler parce
que je crois que j'ai trouvé une place
génial je me gare je te rappelle
[Musique]
elle est magnifique
alors les gars points
[Musique]
Lucie
il est sorti le chien
voilà ça y est ce que je dis
[Musique]
absolument
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais
[Musique]
non pas ici viens Bernie pas ici viens
viens mon gros
merci merci bien
[Musique]
donc j'ai bien fait tu vois
madame déjà
ah oui ça va
ouais ça va je suis désolé j'ai ressorti
le chien c'est pour ça qu'est-ce que tu
fous
[ __ ] en plus tu as mal au dos
pour pas écrire le spectacle d'avant
c'était la couture là c'est la déco
n'importe quoi
c'est qu'on va devoir lui trouver une
place dans l'appartement on va y passer
la journée
dit juste quand il y a Lucie tu pourras
peut-être
tu sais pourquoi tu l'as pris trop grand
est-ce que je suis riche
voilà pourquoi tu mens en plus déménager
pour partir à 50 mètres de ton ancienne
appart franchement je vois pas l'intérêt
mais c'est pour le chien
[Musique]
l'ascenseur ici connard je pouvais
on peut dire qu'elle est sympa moment
elle est sympa mais jamais être une
prochaine recette je suis la seule paire
de couilles de cette baraque et je
compte bien de rester mon petit pote bon
enfin Bernie pascal n'a aucune intention
de me posséder un meuble là quel rapport
ouais
juste tu as pu acheter un œil à mes
blogs les boîtiers tu sais il se
désynchronisent tout le temps du coup
j'ai pas de Wi-Fi ouais ça c'est normal
c'est parce que ça existe pas
le wifi ça existe pas
tu as peut-être plusieurs gens non plus
elle est là
ça va je suis pas bien
merci
donc un rôle de flic lesbienne c'est
intéressant et
une copie hyper marrante voilà donc si
jamais tu as envie de lire du tu me dis
ok super
vous avez commencé à écrire c'est bien
très bien
mais c'était la fête à mon corps
le mec ne va pas laisser dormir s'il te
plaît non deux heures de sommeil tu
plaisantes pas mais je crois que je
travaille encore mieux quand je suis
bourré
je t'ai décroché un rendez-vous chez
Netflix
pourquoi faire
pour prendre un abonnement 9 euros par
mois c'est correct non
tu nous as parlé de ça hier tu as dit je
rêve de faire un français
j'ai un spectacle à écrire pour que tu
veux que je fasse une série et ben tu
feras les deux non enfin en plus sexy en
français enfin tu imagines ce serait
grotesque c'est que scène de City on
achète parce que c'est en anglais donc
évidemment c'est magnifique
notre ami
[Rires]
[Musique]
pour moi c'est pareil je suis allergique
aux deux
si elle était grosse comme une noix de
coco crois-moi que je serai encore au
pieu avec lui alors où je te parle
[Applaudissements]
même en train de boire du lait de coco
[Rires]
[Musique]
je te dis
royal
bonjour bonjour
enfin je vous croise je suis votre
voisin en 6e
que ça doit être un calvaire d'être tout
le temps sollicité
mais bon on va juste faire une petite
photo
à la alors
essayez de se essayer juste quand même
de sourire merci
voilà super de rien
est-ce que c'est pas mieux si si c'est
mieux
non
ouais c'est joli
en plus
pourquoi
le mec regarde le foot à la télé
avec une bougie parfumée sur la table
basse
alors il a le droit d'aimer les Cyclades
je vois pas ce que bien sûr
[Musique]
bonjour
bienvenue
je t'avais dit très très jolie
envie de toucher
alors
vous avez craqué
[Musique]
très très joli enfin tout est beau
vraiment chez vous après c'est dommage
qu'on fasse que l'homme
vous intéresse pas c'est ça
je sais pas enfin moi je sais pas du
tout le créateur moi je suis le vendeur
c'est pas le créateur c'est le vendeur
donc tout va bien
super très joli ça donc c'est pour votre
ami c'est pour mon ami non j'ai pas de
j'ai pas d'amis si j'ai des amis pardon
j'ai pas de petit ami j'ai que des
grands
frères et choses du 44 voilà c'est pas
mon frère ok je vais voir si je les ai
en 44
ça je vous avoue c'est pas mon truc et
oui enfin tu vois bien que c'est pas son
truc faut lui la paix
arrête de l'embêter
ah je t'ai dit que j'avais une place
finalement pour le concert de Mylène
Farmer ah bah fais chier je peux pas y
aller je suis pas dispo c'est quand même
ballot non mais alors je me retrouve
avec une place sur les bras comme ça je
sais pas quoi faire je pourrais faire
plaisir à quelqu'un là-bas quelqu'un qui
aime vraiment Mylène Farmer compris
dites-moi ça vous intéresserait une
place pour Mylène Farmer
et elles sont à combien alors 925
. ouais
il fait du 43 je crois je me suis trompé
tout à je vous ai dit
43 je me souviens maintenant
ah oui du coup bah du coup ça ira du
coup parfaitement
que je vais faire mon frère là
quoi bon oui merci je sais c'est le mien
je sais qu'il est bon j'ai pas fait 1 2
3 4
[Rires]
non pas forestier Foresti tout court
voilà comme
Florence Foresti oui
non je vous disais j'ai un problème avec
mes
plugs en fait parce que je n'arrive pas
à les synchroniser enfin j'y arrive mais
ça ça reste pas quoi je la arrive à un
moment et puis
si je vous le dis c'est
non mon installation électrique je sais
pas je viens d'emménager mais ça a l'air
chouette quoi ça marche
ah oui oui pendant 15 secondes je l'ai
fait 1000 fois oui
ah d'accord ah ok très bien donc on est
aux États-Unis maintenant
avec Mississippi dans ce cas mais là je
peux pas il se trouve je suis toute
seule voilà merci beaucoup vraiment non
je sais c'est pas vous non c'est pas
contre vous mais franchement faites
savoir
faites savoir au-dessus que on en a
marre quoi merci
[Musique]
oui
bonjour
[Musique]
oui Julia c'est moi ça va
ouais non je voulais juste savoir si tu
voulais pas voir un petit coup progrès
vite fait ce soir
mais pourquoi
[Musique]
mais c'est pas grave
d'accord du coup tu l'as récupéré ok non
non moi je comprends mais tu as de la
chance c'est bien en fait la pauvre mais
tu as de la chance quand même quoi oui
oui ma première sandale OK
bisous bisous pardon de t'avoir dérangé
bisous
oui c'est moi ben écoute je voulais
juste parler à titre enfin lui dire
bonne nuit mais j'imagine qu'elle est
couché en fait je suis con
bisous demain enfin quand tu peux et
puis
si jamais si jamais il y a un jour où tu
bosses et que tu as besoin de me la
laisser moi je peux je travaille pas en
ce moment voilà donc si tu as un
empêchement je suis là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va madame faut rester
bonjour vous avez déménagé oui c'est
bien c'est grand alors
je suis désolé je suis pas maintenant en
fait
je croyais et puis
vous avez le
c'est bien parce que vraiment j'étais
vraiment à bout de chauffage donc
comme ça ben c'est très très vite
c'est bien c'est bien
je suis désolé
tout à l'heure j'étais on peut écouter
le coeur peut-être quand même parce que
tout à l'heure c'est pas très très fort
je suis à 160
après je sentais que ça s'est calmé mais
comme j'ai de la siffle pas quand même
je suis désolé
je suis désolé attendez juste je vous
offre un petit verre quand même parce
que je vous ai fait déplacer pour rien
ça me c'est gentil
[Musique]